oh my god David I like the way I look
that's why I don't have a man damn it
woman get your [ __ ] together
Oh what's going on YouTube I'll be
getting a lot of comments from ladies
saying if they can get a man because
they don't like the way they look and
you know what I'm not gonna [ __ ] you
so let me go in and be real for sure
when it comes to initial attraction not
love yes your looks are going to have
something to do with it
I'm sorry for those of you guys out
there that have a lady next to you and
just said I'm not attracted to women for
the way they look anyway you are full of
orangutan [ __ ] what once again looks
will get someone to fall in love with
you for the shirts hell will get the
bees buzzing around the flower you know
I'm sorry
so because you keep on asking about the
physical things that you can do to get
the fellas buzzing ladies hi okay let me
go help you out for this then okay so
get a few tips from Davis o LG a son
let's get it let's go number one ladies
your hair fellas like a lady that can
maintain her locks now I'm not saying
you gotta look go
Gagne through GC [ __ ] but don't be
coming at me with your head looking like
you got in a fight with a weed whacker
and lost comb that [ __ ] brush your flat
on it I don't care but don't be mad at
me when somebody saying you look like
Miss Frizzle and they want to throw you
in front of a Magic School Bus and this
goes out to the sisters too cuz don't
act like you exempt from this role
either oh we don't got Asian people here
why people here I know but still do
something with that [ __ ] get a bucket of
post out on the drawstring ponytail and
do something with that girl because
you're looking like a hot mess and this
is my personal pet peeve with hair wash
it ladies watch your damn hair remember
ladies I grew up in a beauty supply
store initiation information so I've
heard all the excuses if I wash my hair
too much it's gonna be dry and brittle
you so you'd rather look like you
shampooed your head with a bottle of
Crisco ain't gonna lie you to buy the
friend ones who at this issue we went
camping was that she was messing with a
bonfire
I thought the grease yes we're gonna
burn in the flames topic number two the
clothes you gotta do something about the
Wardrobe and no I'm not talking about
dressing like a hoochie coochie
but I'm talking about dressing decently
how are you gonna expect your man to
dressed all nice and clean when you over
here looking like The Hunchback of Notre
Dom if you're comfortable with the way
you dress and you feel good about it
that's fine by me but don't be coming at
me saying I just want
be an individual well guess what when
you're looking like a hot mess you can
be an individual body lonely a self and
yes how you dress is a representation of
yourself so don't [ __ ] it up too much
ladies how are you gonna have your
kiddies all flapping out and getting
Maddie to do for staring at it what if I
was hanging out my shimmer Tang Tang and
I got mad at you for staring at it huh
excuse me eyes appear eyes appear yeah
and for now the last topic your makeup
some of you girls me wearing way too
much of it look I ain't got nothing
against makeup but don't use it like a
weapon girl haven't you heard the same
crack kills ease up the dosage you
cannot be walking around looking like
Krusty the Klown that's ready to take
you seriously so you got two answers
you're happy now once again it's all
about loving yourself and if you do not
like the way you look and you want to
make a change get your ass up and do it
cuz if you're just complaining without
making a move then you just might end up
like me does that scare you huh
the happiest to pull a on earth she
forgot her name huh happiest tabouli on
earth good